welcome to this video playing Alex yeah
this is one of those London system guys
we're always play some kind of anti
London simply to annoy him and I really
managed to completely screw up my rating
here this is a kind of kind of a very
Louis Louis reading let's see can I do
something against this setup yeah I can
I want a game yesterday in mine and this
is a bit weird now because this would be
released much later but I had exactly
the same kind of set up in a live stream
against this player where I am I think I
wonder at the end not very convincingly
I had a completely winning position but
I am screwed up a little bit okay what
I'm going to do here is I'm setting up
almost the Hedgehog double fee and
shadowing and ultimately trying to get
at his c4 porn which in this game that I
played yesterday which worked to
perfection so we're going to see how we
improve is on that I think we have the
same position I'm going to pile up him
and on the sea fowl okay so i can't play
98 trading this which i'm going to do
that then one problem for him Ian from a
from maybe psychological point of view
is that he likes to trade stuff in
general which however is not really
great in this position the more minor
pieces are traded the weaker his c4 porn
will become
so I really don't mind traits I would
have played 94 actually um would have
played 94 and if he had allowed it okay
what is this really wants to take on d7
not earlier no he's happily trading
stuff which is as I mentioned this is
really not helping him but okay I'm
happy to oblige 95 was also possible but
really just trading stuff is good just
when we just have heavy pieces on the
board he will have the only weakness in
c4 it's still dry of course but trading
is no problem at all okay is keeping
that on that one on the board at least
let's see mmm I cannot yet play b5 I
wonder 95 the debatable move maybe but
let's do it it looks kind of annoying
putting more pressure on the sea for
pollen I wonder if maybe maybe even
Bishop d7 a success as a tribe just
detecting that the night on e 1 is not
really doing much in terms of defending
the sea for porn you okay I don't mind
that he weakens in his King side a
little bit nothing serious but every
little thing helps I'm fire head on the
clock amazingly so Bishop 86 how I see
how is he keeping this pawn then I don't
see how I'd be fired but I can take that
and just take see one is hanging or not
let's do that okay rook see form or
stronger move now look c4s is good or
not let's check look-see for look-see
for look-see for Quinn be too
can also take d3 on and let's check Luke
t3 and look sorry roxy foxy for Quinn be
to do I have some tactic they're all
right it's a bit awkward as b5 is
hanging hmm it's a bit awkward so Bishop
takes is going to take a five that's
kind of awkward as well what about
Bishop f4 actually isn't this winning
this is ok right we attack the rook yeah
that's good one of the good moves
attacking the rook and keeping c4 attack
if he takes a 5 I just take de 5 and
take the rook next move so it's just a
clean exchange yeah that's good and the
night leaves the board which is always
kind of kind of kind of helping yep that
there are no no silly a fork tricks ok
let's go e 6 so that i can move both
rooks king is king and save him he only
has a bishop that is not really relevant
for the structure dark squared bishop of
course would be would be a different
matter ok the only thing i have to do is
to make sure that the rooks come off the
board is going for rookie eight maybe ok
let's activate here i should make sure
not to play too slowly h4 h5 is so maybe
still an idea ok root g 7i guess getting
this rooks traded ok cakes pawn takes is
not very I it's not another problem but
ok can play Queen d6 actually and rook
the eight how does he defend his stuff I
guess it doesn't
for up to eight
there are Queen takes default so white
person gives control over the long
diagonal yeah to be perfectly honest I
think is just handling this position not
not very very correctly White has to try
to keep them pieces on the boy not trade
so much and then he was epically happily
am trading stuff it's not as mentioned
it's not like um blackest is winning by
force or anything after the traits but i
think it's it's kind of its kind of
helpful yeah i could have taken on a
three that's also an alternative but
it's not bad now he went back yeah the
problem is if we imagine a situation
where we have everything traded just I
mean I know this is this particular line
doesn't make much sense i know i just
want to show you the general idea if we
come to just heavy pieces i would attack
c4 with the ton of ton of pieces with
all my heavy pieces the sequence here is
bogus yeah i blundered c4 on the way and
so on here the point is even lost but if
you just imagine yeah for for example we
have a situation like that where I am
attacking this a ton of times and he's
defending it here black can just press
forever and ever it's not not much or
anything but they have ideas I have c5f
d5 the right moment I can maybe gain
some space it's a pretty one-sided
position but black can try forever
probably a draw but you can try forever
and he wasn't really trying to avoid
this scenario yeah he Bishop f5 was also
interesting going to his six but this is
not bad but should a six coming yeah
after this it's actually it's actually
over this pawn is falling yeah here Luke
cheeks wasn't I mean it didn't I wasn't
totally sure he a queen bee to is kind
of awkward yeah the computer agrees and
okay I can't take with the bishop but I
didn't want to look at something like
this I mean
just remotely this is looking I mean
okay e5 or h5 does win but you don't
want that and here this is a very clean
win just winning the exchange and yeah
maybe I should have should have avoided
e6e I can play this and this for example
yeah this is in fact simpler yeah but
I'm satisfied that it was an ok game ok
thanks for watching